hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to man of madden man of me
damn man of Madonn I'm sure I'll be
corrected if I'm wrong which I'm sure I
am but this is made by the same creators
of until dawn and the start of some kind
of trilogy don't play alone play alone
well I don't have any friends so I guess
I'm just gonna be playing by myself here
so let's get started oh hi Chinese
market South Sea news story save slot
theatrical cut a weird theatrical cut
okay cool I don't know why they're
painting this to be like a horror movie
I mean it's kind of like a movie like
experience right until dawn was very
cinematic in style it seemed to be like
the creator's wanted to make a horror
movie and then they decided they wanted
a little bit more interactivity to it
which is cool I like the concept I like
a little choose your own destiny kind of
feel the things is you know me but let's
see if this one can cause me to make the
same mistakes I've made before now the
big caveat here is if I make some
game-breaking mistake I don't have time
to go back and play through the whole
game just to save one person and then
replay it in her game to do it correctly
the first time
because number one this is a pre-release
version of the game so if there's any
bugs no nothing I can do about and
there's no guide so nothing can tell me
how I would do wrong if I did do wrong
and I'm leaving for Korea so I'm gonna
be completely out of time this is the
only chance I'll get to play this so
let's see if we can do this right and if
we can't then undo
all right
[Music]
[Applause]
okay well this is sad and overly
dramatic not sure why the music so
bombastic for this you think it'd just
be a tad bit more somber I'm sorry my
air conditioner so it's actually cold in
here hence the code okay
Cheers we having a good time here
everybody's probably not alrighty buster
we better mosey on back to the ship
alright Buster stop what looks like Oh
Charlie charmings got a little business
to attend to
Nino or DOMA oh sure
can I fight hey give me a quarter
why I'm gonna find out my future let's
have it
what's in store for me pop III chase ya
pay yo even MA huh huh tell me about my
son I didn't even know I had a son till
this moment
how's my son doing uh I guess I just
want to know about my son will he is he
gonna grow up all right things gonna
work out for him
uh I like dragons I like I like dragons
kanji job I knew kashama
it's cool that I know Chinese but trying
to figure out why I'm here first so hold
pick up objects use to examine Donna
done it's a fish
looks like a fish you could have told me
that though that's high fool yeah they
come from any direction they sure like a
mysterious wind like this may blow what
happened to my son
wait what wait what does that mean hey
what does that mean what the hell man
what what about my son hey bud let me
get it go away oh yeah think you got the
stuff you know beanie the polio daughter
go home I sure fine sure let me another
quarter I'm gonna start a tab
I'll give it a whirl oh I'll give it a
whirl I'm Joe I love world whoa what is
that that's pretty cool you know nut
back analyzed pretty cool I am take that
low blow with your weird southern hands
uh-huh oh yeah you think oh oh you think
oh no way no how yeah okay yeah yeah
lady or Dee I don't know which buttons
which hey I don't know mark just say
left right up I can't I can fight ooh
that's what you get
Oh dodge should I be playing this with a
controller or something cuz I feel like
oh boy I feel like I don't know these
buttons as you have them written Wow
yeah looks like I'm the karate master
now that's Jeff that's Japanese Thank
You Sean one piece shits in a Japanese
we better get back to the ship we don't
want to get stranded come on man just
let me ask another question see how you
would play this with your friends if you
are both doing the challenges at the
same time but me I have no friends
[Music]
if only we invented radios I could tell
you that [ __ ] oh that's not dangerous
don't drop it anyway how's the wife
oh good more skulls great I don't know
what we got from China I don't know why
we're here
oh yeah there we go hey aren't you proud
of us
5650 come on
Wow hey all that karate didn't help me
none
get this one to the medical
the other and the free what's what's
with these performances I just got to
say I know this is a pre-release version
then maybe it's not finalized but this
comes out in a few days
what's with those performances hood him
in the brig and keep him there I don't
want to make fun of it just in case it
gets better but even if it does get
better then that's just gonna suggest me
that maybe it shouldn't oh no not the
skulls Oh No
if only I shouted at him well that was
weird
oh that's not that's what you call not
good now I see why you were playing
mysteriously creepy music zombies
it's going to be zombies
I got punched me hard yeah we don't want
him to wake up from this
their sedation didn't work I seem to be
up Joe sickbay Joe no last name that's
what they call me just Joe with a
mysterious maybe dead son all right cool
Joe's up and Adam let me look at this
pick that up I learned this in
fortune-telling school all right kid you
could smile once or twice in your life
too pops come back soon Wow kid you got
great hand right yeah real good
handwriting kid
that's right impressive good job son I'm
proud of you okay
can I move oh I can't move okay using my
key bird the controls are a little weird
okay first aid yeah let's get some paint
I was just looking for quarters quarters
found me no I missed I was going for the
quarters what is this garbo what is this
one of those TI's all right whatever
whatever you say now back for the
quarters okay hey you get any more
quarters in you something tells me I
should be playing this out of control
there because I feel like the keyboard
not particularly set up for that okay
well enough nothing to say about that
just a regular old dead body
no no opinions one way or another I
can't move w I you know I am trusting W
and yet W seems to not be working I will
make the executive decision to switch to
a control R oops
never mind it's frozen
back to the body and away from the body
can I move now oh I can move okay let's
see if I can up there we go I think this
will be a much more pleasant experience
with the controller
okay well I'm certainly in no hurry all
right easy as pie I mean now that I
haven't done the tutorial I'm sure this
is gonna go very good for me loved it I
gotta say it looks great I just need to
find out how to walk the controls are
just a tad bit clunkier than they may
seem to show you know it's not me being
too terribly stupid but I'm a little
dumb loud 2d he'll cut see I can hardly
tell the daddy Charlie how's your time
off just get me out of here already dead
by your crap the dead God might be too
and there was a corpse what's in the
sick bay something's wrong let's get out
of here
all right whatever you say man okay just
clip through my shoulder like that are
you guys doing good in here in that
private Charles Anderson on leave from
duty to display intoxication and the man
are not becoming up a member of the US
Army private Anderson was engaging with
another soldier in a drunken argument it
is the opinion of the arresting officer
that this would lead to a public brawl
and the steps were taken to ensure the
both men were returned to their ship all
right cool thank you well glad that the
paperwork was done in triplicate for
that I'm glad that we are in proper
order for all this hey can I take a piss
or something I don't seem to be in too
much of a hurry about this whole dead
body situation but you know what is in
the ever ooh I see a sailboat all right
nothing to say man I've got no opinions
all right what if we get here
mon-monday Arthur petty theft small
items belonging to senior officer found
in Miller's locker items recovered and
returned to owner found off limits in
cargo hold 3a with no reason to be their
flagrant disregard for orders found
drunk and acting inappropriately from US
Army personnel while on shore leave I'm
drunk and acting inappropriately for US
Army watch shore leave I guess they were
too dumb whoever those mysterious guys
were not me for sure what are the odds
well not open funny about that oh oh boy
here for my friend to arrive Oh friend
ha all right let's go
don't waggle your left joystick at me Oh
God they walk like zombies already if
these guys don't
Keep Calm we're saying it's a rhythm
game good thing all that guitar hero got
me there here we go oh I don't got hold
it
easy easy
Easy's hi Sarge we can help you Sarge
Sarge you really gotta learn you gotta
work on your turning left ability
yeah boy that sergeant loves to shout it
bass fry no he could have been saying hi
to his neighbor who knows it just likes
to shout oh yeah buddy I'm on doorway
hang on gonna check something you know
me always love checking corridors
it's obvious they put so much work into
this game and it looks really nice but
my god do they look like idiots when
they're walking around oh oh they walk
like upper room for nothing I guess just
my imagination just that weird wind
blowing through here boy
ah see shiny thing i'ma go look for
shiny
hey Charlie help Charlie look so dumb I
don't know I feel bad Oh Nick and me
what I'm just gonna hold the button down
I hate button mashing that's the
stupidest thing in the world that's not
a challenge I could do it on my mouse
button I would be able to do that um
okay Han let's go try that again because
I'm pretty sure that I can do this now
that I've got my newfound powers and
abilities he's gonna be a walk in the
cake for that face oh all right okay I'm
there all right let's see if it'll work
hold him down okay good great good blue
bar then Oh found a nice box to die on
looks like he's been shot but why okay
but what about that other door then wait
was there another rules oh I can't go
really how am I supposed to know which
doors the secret door and which door is
not the secret door well I get there
goes my hundred percent oh wow Charlie
standing there all creepy-like huh how
am I supposed to know last time I saw
him in the mess hall he was a poor
[ __ ]
I mean fiddles don't usually move either
so I guess this is all the same here
don't know why Saul rigor mortis already
but whatever I guess weird okay
let me hang on a second here I changed
my mind
Harley you wait there definitely make
sure you get enough air through your
mouth don't forget to breathe nope
nothing just simply might've maybe
looked like there was something but
turns out there was not anyway Charlie
I'm following you I'm following you
bleed I follow hold left bumper to walk
faster put one foot more forward than
other foot and you go farther in less
time it's just true science Charlie
Charlie you swings wrong your arms when
you walk a little more you go bigger on
the distance your distance go bigger so
yeah oh hey Chuck you see that
no feeling all right no no no not uh no
no I'm not apparently I'm seeing a child
you think that we would be less calm
about this good thing our training
goddess cool as cucumbers more dead
bodies
[Music]
funny charlie they look like us when you
were walking in standed but they're not
moving sorry had to load charlie Oh got
these [ __ ] look look he's just
walking like a goddamn zombie
there better be a plot whistling they're
already infected here something that's
weird
come here
that's not very funny oh god no charlie
oh hey kid
Oh looking as healthy as ever they well
I don't know how to boom okay all right
well then you know
[Music]
Oh Charlie I forgot to breathe oh and I
warned you about breathing it was so
hard
forget for one minute dude why are they
Morse coding with
[Music]
okay I'm just
I'm gonna go ahead and say it you know
until dawn had a lot of
[Music]
why don't you spare me / - no haha is
this the man of me Dan oh I take back
everything I was about to say
[Music]
okay I love prog-rock this is him isn't
it it's the man of mythic hello hi and
welcome to my repulsive thank you
I like it I like repositories never been
in one myself okay never mind I guess
that was weird okay hello I am the
curator the curator of stories choices
of love mr. Hayes keep doing that greed
and beauty life and death stories such
as this
I'm here to record the story you choose
to tell you see this tale is only part
written and the choices you make will
complete it and determine whether the
lives of those with whom you are
interfering continue to flourish or
whether they are snuffed out
you see we each make decisions according
to our own moral compass and we have to
live with those decisions or die by them
but you shouldn't fear death it is after
all inevitable it is the tax one pays
for having lived and it comes eventually
to everybody still none of us want for
it to come to sue do know as in life the
actions you take matter okay the choices
you make will affect others
I'll be keeping a close eye on your
progress it's not my place to interfere
but I might be persuaded to offer the
occasional hint here's one for free
there are pictures in this world that
can show you some possible futures if
you can find them and study them they
may just help you to make better
decisions
or should I say decisions that result in
the outcomes you would prefer oh okay
there for the moment we'll talk again
soon enough we'll have the opportunity
to account for all the actions that
you've taken uh-huh all right I love the
way you punctuate every sentence with a
musical cue it's really nice methinks
the game has a few bugs here and there
but I will forgive that for I have this
game early slap slap slap all right
where am I now
brat witty Brad Alex's brother innocent
okay Brad
no one has blast names here Brad what's
up hey Brad
Alex motivated Brad's brother Julia's
boyfriend insecure he looks it Brad I'm
so insecure oh I don't know if I can
hold that beer I don't know if we ran
out we can always call for backup
maybe I don't like talking on the phone
I've never been down there before down
the water diving maybe you could show me
how the pros do it are you serious yeah
I mean are you serious who came out here
without taking any lessons kind of yeah
but oh no I'm not insecure I'm not
insecure at all
it's embarrassed what does that mean oh
[ __ ] oh [ __ ] it's what it's embarassing
taking them by yourself it's
embarrassing you came all the way out
here expecting me to hold your hand
would bro whoa careful
row that dive cam is like super
excellent bro be cool what Julianne
Conrad are you know how do I say super
[ __ ] loaded so so don't sweat the
wolf stuff man it's not cool don't make
me regret letting you tag along
what I was invited I think I was invited
uh tag along seriously I thought it was
invited Julia wanted you to come along
for real Julia yeah man she wanted you
to come I wanted her to see how cool you
are
which you're not so be cool capisce all
right amigo Calvary is almost here whoo
sorry I'm a little snappy I'm just a new
medical school would be stressful you
know total shocker and man the
long-distance thing with Julia it's been
rough
I'm pathetic
yeah I got you it must be tough I guess
I was in the keyboard now huh yep right
I like you what Conrad doesn't think we
have enough beer ah because I keep these
and an undisclosed location yeah
relationship updated ooh
oh this is very untold on helpouts
prepare for his trip eager anxious
innocent secret secrets never tell the
good secrets go to hell anyway sorry I
don't know what came over me
our beef trades update I don't care hey
what were you saying brother
what
kind of a big thing I'm trying to make a
decision about don't get married about
finishing med school no but it's just
kind of a big life Joe no I don't know
what's the right thing to do go with
your gut go goddamn go with your golf
player look you're good if it's right
you'll know that's what I always say
never think about decisions always act
jump into it Hockley excited
I can tell reckless Conrad Dooley
brother foolhardy relaxed these are
interesting traits sorry Connie this is
Alex hey what's up man
Conrad watch it sis Ladykiller right
here
good to finally meet you kyrat it's Brad
by the way a little bro hey Bradley feel
like I already know you have heard so
much about you yeah likewise amen
want a crack : with me want some crack
yeah yeah yeah uh uh beer that beer is
lit it's fire you could say words now
right on radical I like the cut of your
ship it's Jim
you ever do any diving before yeah buh
doo buh dude all the time totally all
the time totally I'm so tight when I
dive stick me with a noob uh-huh nope
not new not new I know nurse ear
underwater at this point with the tank
so here I belong a couple three times
you know here and there family trips
[Laughter]
where's the old crust bucket skipper any
other Flis impatient captain of the Duke
of Milan courageous all right I'd invite
you to make yourselves at home but
so is everybody on board and ready to go
[Music]
you think they would have met this
captain before they just heard slapping
their beer all over
[Music]
what a courageous leader type what a
boss I like it
man I gotta say no I can't say yeah
because we're still alive in the movie
excuse me
just fishing well get it all in more
like I open my mouth just follow the
bottle like them yeah you know maybe I
should maybe I should maybe what about
over here that's pretty far out of the
way I'm just thinking about backup
targets in case we don't find anything
on the dive cam listen to be honest I've
never heard of this direct you're
looking for usually these things are
crawling with divers yeah this is
different I'm just saying if it gets too
late I know some nice places where you
can just take you know a nice dive look
I'm optimistic Brad did his homework did
his homework if he says the wrecks here
it's here okay you're the client I'm
just saying we don't have unlimited
daylight I'm gonna go help Conrad and
jewel you with the camera feast your
eyes on this whoa mama lesions were
right on the money always bet on bright
kids a whiz we should thank him what we
found a plane yeah yeah looks like world
war two we are ready to dive technically
we should call this in to port
authorities as an unreported wreck
well technically are you sure you don't
want to do this the right way uh can we
can't dive wait are you saying we
shouldn't dive the right way come on
what is this kindergarten I had to bring
it up if we just go down and take a look
who's gonna know fine as long as you're
quick don't touch anything
what's the point of dying first one down
there can you imagine I'm touched
do we touch it touch touched it
with my touch you guys in the water in a
few boys I'll do the final checks take a
look at the camera see if you can find
anything useful
all right right oh maybe you should
check on your bro nothing else to say
about that okay my tires
oh I'm touching now okay all right dude
dude enough dive right in no what's this
oh gonna take a look e leu what so
calming so to be this funny here we go
now I can walk maybe hmm thought I saw a
dead body
nope okay I will look alright those less
aggressive than I thought it'd be yeah I
don't know what it is about this game
what some things are just really steep
I mean until dawn it had its oakiness
but it was like a the acting was a bit
more fluid in like the interactions were
a bit more fluid I don't know what
happened I like pictures as lag pictures
there's just like a fundamental
disconnect that makes it seem like these
people are just like aliens in human
bodies
trying to cool with each other and try
to be like yes me and human me dive me
emotion missing commotions me maybe boo
but maybe you and like the other
characters seem to have like more not
distinctive because these ones have
distinctive bro I'm just looping they're
the same because these ones have
distinctive personalities but also more
like more engaging personalities I'd say
hey hey hey hi
alright what did you say sorry I'm sorry
yeah sorry about before alright
everybody just a little we've been
planning this whole thing for a while
now I get it
but there are rules and laws and customs
these rules are all pretty basic stuff
how much experience do you have with
these kind of dives
self-assured dived a couple wrecks over
the years I'm expert but you know
experienced if this is your first
unreported wreck then you should know
there's a very specific protocol you
have to follow for all you know this
could be a war grave disturbing it would
be illegal and immoral let's see who's
gonna know belligerent or pompous you
know what I can't stop guys thank Jessie
respect the rules down thanks a lot
don't do anything stupid that'll get my
ass in trouble walked right through that
threaded the needle I saw the
opportunity and I swam right through it
that was that little hello
you know your brother can't handle his
drink just a little seasick I'm
impressed you found this wreck really
well yeah thanks done with that I guess
I'm done okay so I'm done okay
boop-boop-boop by booty bye okay so this
is the rebreather way cooler than a
regular scuba setup it takes all that
co2 that you'd normally just exhale into
the water and instead it gets totally
reused then it reduces decompression
time on your way up stay tuned here
Oh to check done wait no but I was gonna
I need to talk to my brother wait no I'm
not ready to go I gotta check out my
brother what I'm good Jay good Jay that
like stake you underwater Hey
what no that's my sis you're talking
about this is not what Kay you little
clown fishes what gonna go see what
bliss is up to wait no what wait but I
need to talk them wait go back
what brother okay
ha oh we will
I thought that mayhaps I had been
screwed okay I guess this is it
ton or a camera I like Amara's you're on
camera I'll take the wheels let's get it
before photo all right kids
good to go wait no I guess I'll take
this this seems important was this stun
rod oh yeah I got the bang stick heard
about you ha ha you ever have to use one
yeah on a shark nope
Oh guess we're done talking then hey I
wanted I wanted to go talk to my brother
guys this is not my fault I wanted to go
talk to my brother I had no idea that
talking to Julia would just be like
[Music]
freaky bread puddings who needs a
brother not me here we go then I guess
that's problem that's what you call a
problem so tight plane Hey
souvenir would be cool it's not like one
tiny little thing would hurt anybody I
won't tell if you all not like they get
to scan the wreck every night at sundown
yeah that's cheap that's gotta be it's
pretty good time to watch your mouth
howdy captain you fancy a pint with your
second-in-command
you are not my second-in-command third
in command no fresh in your cabin will
Atilla know your well-paying dashingly
handsome seafaring client
it's requesting the pleasure of your
company over a frosty amber liquid oh
definitely no then pass I need to focus
I mean if I was her I would definitely
do that I need to focus
Pass I have to stay focused on your
friends down there good call good call
that was not smooth where'd you get the
cash don't ask the lady about her money
no it's not polite to ask a lady about
her money fair enough I was just
thinking about buying a boat myself and
I thought maybe I'd like to point me in
the right direction it would be my
pleasure not really sorry I have got
enough on my plate for the moment see so
beep boop boop boo boo boo boo spend
some time keeping the Duke of Milan
shipshape
hi if I don't push these buttons in
right beep ooh border the whole ship
bruised yeah here we go beep oh beep
looks clear yeah well they're good
getting mighty crowded out here little
blip what you doing all the way out here
well I guess I'm done beeping no more
beeping no more open so if you click on
the back button the whole thing just
locks up interesting interesting
interesting interesting but if you press
the button to go back if you move it if
you go people okay there I go here I all
right well don't know where I'm going I
bukey I pick him again oh don't think
about maybe not here we go see mrs. du
Bois this letter is a formal
notification that you are default of
your application to make regular
payments on your personal loan the loan
hogs a remainder of twenty four thousand
seven other netted three dollars within
some of 3481 payable by first of August
yes I'm late this amount has been over -
since that date and you appear to have
ignored lots of all requests for
payments already discussed do
reconsolidate your day unless they are
standing out the amount of three
thousand four hundred and eighty one
dollars is received about the 30th of
august she owned in nineteen we will
have no choice but to begin the
foreclosure process against your
collateral namely de marine vessel they
do chameleon accordingly yours shall
sauron señoras can't manage ah well
that's a sad depressing letter I have to
repeat at the same time every day during
exposition hey Pookie I bukey begin yeah
I guess your brother doesn't like you oh
this is the toilet dry guys
a favorite painting this always relaxes
me why do I keep these around good
question cut and run what
so is that don't cut and run so don't
cut and run I'm not getting it I mean
I'm gonna be shot if I'm gonna take that
as if I cut and run I will be shot good
know what about this nothing
fifty Shades of Shroud of innocence
okay that was going for the book but de
Parfum is good dear never mind it's not
as good as I once suspected now a must
read for anyone with an interest in the
sale I'm sorry I apologize this is not
the time for silliness where is that
sleeping brother rather how's it going
knocked out by cold frosty man I feel
like such a wimp hey it's your vacation
you're allowed to overdo it
maybe I am officially starting a
temperance Club party of one lifetime
membership asked well I'm talking about
oh I guess we're done talking hey Flis
look there's a boat
a premonition we're about to be boarded
that is not the Coast Guard so we're not
under arrest
perhaps should we handle this this feels
off this feels off just be quiet and
don't say anything stupid okay
[Music]
guys you gotta keep back we've got
divers in the water
[Music]
hey we got damage here you see this look
at our boat we can take care of this man
it's not a problem what do you think
like 10 bucks cover it oh whoops my bad
let's make it 20 well shoot you you
think it's more like 30 I can do 30
hey guys drive a hard bargain but I'm
with you here but just throwing the
whole pot right why why you be that way
that you are what why bot why do ye what
what what what what what Oh weird
amateur bar here I'm an [ __ ] I'm a
douchebag Oh a dickweed take the whole
pot okay oh that's not good anyway
all right saddest man um a damn Conrad
said one of the pictures showed an
opening Conrad really really the rear
turret economy
but turn we can get in through there
all right cool good glad this is
riveting III hey three dangerous ladies
first
hold on just one second that was not my
fault that was not my fault because my
hand was not on the keyboard beat ku as
I was so flabbergasted at Conrad's
personality I couldn't bother that was
not my fault
didn't know I was gonna have to play
[Laughter]
what premonition oh hey devil in the
deep okay no no no no okay I don't
remember it all - until dawn if they
show the things that you're supposed to
do or not supposed to do I don't
remember if they're like do this thing
or maybe don't do this thing you know
what I mean
okay so don't do that but does that mean
to do do the other thing I am comfy
it's exploring go go go whoa hole I
found a hole why we wanna leave it you'd
have to take your gear off to get in
there not worth it
that place is pretty tight what if you
get stuck without your rebreather don't
be such a gonad
I'll be fine go dad seriously am i dead
what's happening this seems like a bad
idea but okay I guess I'm doing it now
the ability to like make decisions and
seem to be very different from what it
was before
also I there's very little actual yeah
okay maybe this was a bad idea
Oh
[Music]
cam ready to 8 oops
really I don't know
you did something stupid down here
that's it one chance you get that chill
out I'm fine see no problemo no problemo
and I got a letter
ooh searched area one area to area this
was worth getting this was very worth a
plane was on the way to help out a ship
it's a traits updated generous cunning
selfish courageous compassion whoa what
Alex took the bank stick on the dive
proposal Brad told Alex to follow his
gut I see okay all right here I go
Oh what's this give me give me that's a
bullet fuselage Brad's gonna flip when
he sees this bread loves bullets I don't
know Fred hates bullets I don't know if
flipping is a good thing your lingo is I
think they were using it let's see what
else we can find
I'm not sure how much of a secret these
secrets are Oh
yes sir touch touch it's touched I'm
doing doing doing
you've doing okay and looky loo and
looky loo in looky loo Wow a precious
keepsake oh I wonder if she knows well
would that never mind
look things they knew they were goners
how do you know that what what how did
you know how would you know that bad
bang stick father call a bang stick bang
oh you got a bang stick too I see oh I
might think it's hard to tell sometimes
I think what does that when life gives
you lemons when you piss your pants
what what are you gonna do with my
lemonade and co-pilot
what are you gonna do a limited oh okay
this is happening now
now we'll go up then it's open now let's
go I'll kill you kill you shark hold on
this is the right time but I really
really didn't know if it was the right
time really really no times great time
really now yes really now I know you
can't tell these are underwater but
about my knees right now uh-huh now baby
ah astounded we almost thought yeah it's
[ __ ] stunned ah crap Julia I'm
serious damn sure wow what a goddamn
story
how's it end oh man this is gonna be
with death trap yeah this is Julia we're
coming back up over here we go goodbye
wait Julia we got a decompress here Wow
damn what the [ __ ] we gotta get up there
we we have to decompress no you've got
the know we we've got the special suits
no you have this special this crazy just
got wait a few seconds you got this
god it's taking too long this is torture
just a few more seconds okay now go go
what the hell happened it's cool man
everything's all right now
oh nothing your brother just took it
upon himself to blow up my grill Conrad
what is wrong with you why are you
paying me oh [ __ ]
so why are you paying the ocean a group
of fishermen came by and damaged their
boat they got caught on the dive line
Oh that's what happened yeah so then
ambassador Conrad figured the best
movies to show him he'd rather throw
away his money than give it to them
you're an [ __ ] whatever Oh what I
want to know is what you guys find no
plane and it's huge full of cool stuff
oh my god you guys can you all just shut
up for like one second hopefully [ __ ]
dude bro crap nicely done come up and
let's celebrate this is weird but this
is weird
this is not how humans interact this is
not how humans human this is weird
hi Hey sorry Hey how you doing mr.
Madden you're getting to know these
intrepid adventurers then Alex and his
little brother Brad trying to swim with
the big fish
both seem out of their debt yeah and
Julia the love of Alex's life and he the
love of her yep
what about Conrad a bold fellow you
might say or maybe you'd say arrogant
and then there's captain Flitz strong
forthright stubborn she appears somewhat
immune to Conrad's charms so far at
least let me reassure you you help them
to make some decisions they'll value
later on you're doing well yay yeah I'm
not did well I'm good this game is Han
we're gonna pause here this game is a
little ridiculous in a way very
different from how until dawn was very
very different but I am enjoying myself
that is at the end of the day that is
what matters I am in fact enjoying
myself in this game I'm laughing
probably a lot more than I should be
laughing but I'm having a blast play it
is just it's so weird because the acting
is very stiff there's no denying that
the action is very stiff I am NOT
playing this game much though the only
thing I've done is move around and miss
a few QuickTime events so frankly I'm
apparently doing pretty good I didn't
get to talk to my brother before I left
but apparently that didn't mean jack
doodlee so I will pick this up next
thank you everybody so much for watching
let me know you thought down in the
comments below and let me know how you
think I'm doing because frankly
apparently I'm doing good but I don't
know don't feel like it but if you
haven't seen until dawn I'll put a
playlist in the description below so you
can see that one it is a lot of fun it
is very interesting and it is a quite a
surreal experience but thanks again and
as always I will see you
in the next video bye-bye
[Music]